all right welcome everybody glad to be
back
for the week it is an early starting
stream today because there's an early
uh press briefing scheduled for just
about a half hour from now so we're
going to have time
to look at a bunch of different things
and we are going to
uh it's just going to be a good day i
think i have mimetic elements
i have voicemails i have new tech
things to talk about what time does the
stream normally start there is no
no sometimes there's no stream there is
no normal time but let me talk you
through some of the different things
that are going on
as some of you may know we are in the
process of redoing
all of our graphics for them to all be
cohesive
so youtube twitter all these things have
been updated we now have updated
the logo in that's behind me to also
match what's going on
elsewhere which is a really really great
thing that's happening and it's exciting
number two i have an extra microphone
whoa
i have an extra microphone here it's not
currently hooked up to anything
but what i thought i would do is right
now when we do callers
it sounds great on stream but the
callers
can't hear me well because they're
hearing me through a webcam
that's really far away so my thought was
to hook this up and have it right down
here
so that the this is just for the callers
to hear me
and then hopefully that will reduce some
of the limited problems that of course
we have with uh callers
hearing me or not hearing me or whatever
so i think that that will be good
and that is um something that that we're
gonna put in place
as soon as i find a cable for that
microphone
uh oh hold on i think i have a cable
right here i think we're gonna be in
in good shape so that's going to be good
um and then what else i guess that's
really
it from the standpoint of tech i
do want to deal with chaka seki's
super super chat which is just off
screen but it is there chaka seki says
david are you going to schedule another
hangout with matt dillahunty i had the
pleasure of seeing him debate the
dim-witted vulgarian dinesh d'souza in
march of 2020
love the atheist experience yes planning
to reschedule with uh with matt soon
i had what we call a technical issue and
i tweeted by the way
about dinesh d'souza yesterday i said
whoa
i've got to get myself some of those my
pillow gym jams this is
uh dinesh d'azuza offering my
pillow jammies with a promo code
dinesh in case you were
i don't i don't in case of what i don't
know in case you were wondering if
dinesh d'azuza endorses
pajamas these are the pajamas that he
endorses
okay so that is that and we have gotten
that
um out of the way okay good
um welcome to everybody yes yes yes i'm
still
i'm still doing super chats uh i see
people confused on twitch that even
though it is february 1st
you are still a subscriber on twitch how
could this be possible
twitch subs run for a month no matter
what day you sign up
so if you signed up on january
18th for example you will be a sub
until february 18th it doesn't all
clear on february 1st
what else um
oh thanks to astrolycos for cheering a
thousand bits i love that that's very
exciting
and in fact i wanna say thanks to the
three folks who just grabbed
uh twitch subscriptions very much
appreciate that
uh that puts us at three and then also a
big thank you to
anastasia lind lindquist
anastasia lindquist and
mackenzie henderson as well as len
sokol all of whom just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
we have a short month this month we're
going to have to hit that joinpacman.com
extra hard
what do you use for your sub and
membership goal progress bar oh
these are all custom javascript elements
custom javascript elements fear
doves yuldeshev says hi david love what
you do
thank you thoughts on the myanmar coup
says nicholas i'll probably talk about
that tomorrow i don't yet know enough
about it to be able to say anything
intelligent right now
so uh i'm gonna i'm gonna wait and
discuss that tomorrow
okay a few things to go over let's see
where to even
start have i seen the recent documentary
the dissident about
jamal khashoggi i have not but i want to
see that i want to see that and i
apologize i
uh did not mute my phone which i will do
now
okay listen i predicted
that the case peak would be i know so
many of you are tired of me saying this
i predicted the case peak would be
somewhere between january
10th and 15th uh and it appears as
though
that is happening as you can see the
seven-day average peaked on january 11th
and we are going
down down down we are down to an average
of 150 k a day
we have to go all the way back to
november
14th to get back to a lower number
that's great news i subsequently
predicted
these are not particularly insightful
predictions but just because we know
death slag cases by three to four weeks
that the death peak would be right
around now february 1st
we don't yet know exactly
but as you can see we have been at this
kind of plateau
on average deaths for a couple of weeks
we're hoping to see that go down soon
it is now a race between the variants
and the vaccines we know that the
variants
make the vaccines slightly less
effective
particularly the south african but maybe
not less effective enough
to prevent immunity important to
understand
just because there's a reduced antibody
response
against the south african variant from
the vaccines
doesn't mean the response isn't
sufficient to prevent you
uh from getting sick we're still
learning about this
but it's it's just a race we just have
to vaccinate as quickly as possible
and fortunately vaccination numbers
continue to improve
um we had three very strong days with
1.7
and 1.6 doses and then yesterday
1.3 million doses my prediction
this week we will get to 2 million doses
in a 24-hour period
we really want to be at 3.5 million
that's really where we want to be
and on today's bonus show
i discuss um vaccination as it relates
to me
so that's on today's bonus show david
i'm hearing the impeachment trial in the
senate will display
video and graphic evidence unlike last
time do you intend to cover
you know i haven't just i wanna i'm
going to cover i think that
not covering the impeachment trial would
be lame
covering all of it would be impossible
for me to do
so i'm going to cover some i'm going to
cover some
my partner and i am public school
teachers in massachusetts
where did you find your info on student
to teacher coveted transmission
we're being forced back february 22nd
i'm not sure what information you're
referring to mina i apologize
we're still waiting for the hulk hogan
mustache
so yeah um i'll i'll make a deal if
people care about this and why should
you care about this we're here for the
news but if people care about this i was
going to reshape
my goatee today i was going to get rid
of everything other than this and trim
it to a uniform length
if we get to our hundred website members
and twitch subs i will commit right now
to today okay i will shave this
area and i will create a hulk hogan
mustache
i will go tomorrow on the show and if
we're lucky enough for there to be a
stream or maybe wednesday i'll figure
i'll do it in the next couple days
i will do just a full mustache that goes
from down here
all the way around and down okay all
right who cares
anyway i know some people have been
waiting for that
um big thanks to dennis karen as well
for signing up at joinpackman.com all
right
i have a couple i have a couple
directions we can go right now
i can go maga cringe compilation
or i can go voicemails
what do people prefer mega cringe
compilation
or voicemails we'll do both i'm just
asking which do you want first
oh it's pretty split 50 50. i know i can
do a poll guys
it's just funnier for me to look at the
chat because then i have to evaluate
it looks like people are reacting early
to uh
to mega cringe all right let's look at
the mega cringe compilation
i don't know how many of these are real
again i am telling you
i don't know how many of these are real
let's listen i don't know why
i put the people that kill babies
and hate and want to live their lives
completely opposite of his word
why they succeed
in allah and while the people that serve
him
and live their life as best as they can
like is this real or is this
a satire i the fact that we can't tell
is telling
by his law continue to suffer
then now the left is going to say that
we're the snowflakes
well yeah
i got full grown pastors okay
full grown adult men
sending me text messages sending me
inbox messages
asking me when i'm going to repent and
resign my church because
i said trump was going to win the
election and trump didn't win let me
tell you
trump won by landslides oh okay
listen i'm almost ashamed of these
pastors and preachers and prophets that
say well
i'm gonna have to apologize no you ain't
gotta apologize for nothing he won
single-handedly hands down biggest so
some of these we've covered i'm more and
we did
this lady already we did that lady um
yeah let's go to this guy i'm curious
what this guy has to say
hold on a second here it is oh hey just
facts
so the first day in office the first
person
joe biden fired was a black man
the surgeon general what did he do so
wrong to you joe biden
answer me that question and then y'all
call
donald trump a racist
wow you stole the election joe
you stole the election sleepy creepy joe
imagine these people thinking that this
is going to have an impact on the
discourse
and now you're letting your racist
sideshow
you say that you want to unite this
country
stop racism but the first person you
fire
is a black man hey by the way i just saw
a really great idea in the chat
if anybody if joe woodward's in the chat
jethro bradley
uh david domini or uh
dj physic or anybody who does our
remixes
it would be really great to do a remix
of either um
uh hold on a second either fleetwood mac
or anybody doing landslide where we
replace the word
landslide with a music musification
of uh music evasion musification
of trump or others saying landslide
about their victory that's the idea
if people can get to that and if you can
even include some elements from the
david pakman show in it i think that
that would be really interesting
don't look too good on you joe
jesus forever rig 2020.
that's you my fellow patriots no need to
worry
so listen is this some kind of filter
i'm not joking is her face filtered here
interaction law is in place now uh what
trump wrote back in 2018
is now in place uh which stated
anybody who commits treason on our
country
will be arrested uh-oh i hope a lot of
those people are arrested then
and military will take place
this is why washington right now looks
like a [ __ ] prison
um let me go further so see basically
when trump said how does someone like
this you can can someone like this solve
a quadratic equation
like i i'm not joking what i mean is if
you're so deluded you believe this stuff
could you do math and i know there are
republican mathematicians it's not about
that it's a certain level of delusion
where like if you said to her
hey you know um uh
x squared minus 25 how would you
simplify that or
i i it's just so hard for me to imagine
yesterday in his farewell speech
you'll be seeing me soon the new
administration is going to be amazing
the new administration
i'm bored guys these people are bonkers
i'm gonna get away from it yeah we know
they exist i'm gonna get away from it
let me get instead to some of the
voicemails i have i know people are very
anxious to hear about the voicemails
um okay a few super chats though
solve you think she knows the quadratic
formula no for some i don't think she
does
no my sister's family all got the
fuchiser vaccine
two weeks later they got an asymptomatic
covid
i have heard this happens to many
how would they even think to get tested
if they had no symptoms that's weird
david if you're going to get hulk hogan
mustache you need to at least go for it
until the end of march
if you agree i'll go subscribe to both
the website and twitch right away to
keep it i'm not committing to how long
i'm keeping it i'll keep it i mean
i'll keep it as long as i guess my
girlfriend allows me to
uh i meant that parents cite student
transmission with disregard for teacher
ability to contract the virus anyhow
anyhow
and gracias yes tomorrow is my birthday
um just the best birthday present is
people signing up on joinedpakman.com
that's all we need i can't believe to
say
i said i have to say this but i prefer
magga over q anon
interesting okay well that's certainly
something
i do want to say thanks to the eight
additional subscribers
at join pacman.com no in all seriousness
though
we had a very rough january
from the standpoint of memberships as as
many of you guys know me
our website is like the primary funding
source for our show
just a lot of people in financial
problems mem just massive
dumps of memberships people dumping them
like getting rid of them
because of financial reasons people
saying david i can't do the two bucks a
month i can't do the dollar 88 a month
so in all seriousness i this is a
i know we joke around a lot about
memberships i would love it
if you grabbed a membership at
joinedpakman.com with or without the
coupon code the coupon code is available
we're not
means testing it in any way but i would
love it if you grabbed a membership
i will thank members on stream and if we
get to 100
in the next couple days i will show up
and do a show
with a uh with a handlebar
mustache or i'm sorry a hulk hogan
mustache handlebar is out
right i'm not doing out i'm doing like
the
yeah anyway whatever that is who the
hell knows can i recite the quadratic
equation
um is that quadratic equation is that
uh a a squared
plus uh hold on a square i mean it's
been so long that i've done this
is it a squared plus
a b plus b
now i don't remember
a squared plus b equals c squared that's
the pythagorean theorem isn't it
yeah people are sending me the
pythagorean theorem
ax squared plus bx plus c equals zero
there it is
there it is that's not that's an
equation though
okay oh my god people are going
absolutely crazy right now
let's talk about memberships instead
it's much better all right
let me get to some voicemails okay um
we did talk about um
anal swabs last week for covid china
rolling out anal swabs the egg man who
we love
checked in with a voicemail about this
hey dave
i agree with you that if um you have
like seven or eight friends and they've
all tested negative
and they wear masks and you're gonna
have a little gathering in your house
and they come to your house and you have
um on the spot
tests to give them right there with
immediate results
i would definitely have a party too and
have a gathering but i'd like to ask you
if you only have anal swaps available
are you going to anal swab all of your
guests as they come into your front door
shallow brother yeah you know i i
figured out the way that
that that swab works is if you swab
and you can't smell anything you
probably have covid because
covet affects your sense of smell so
there's the eggman checking in we love
the eggman and his sense of timing and
delivery is
absolutely perfect um
okay so that's eggman
um and then i have
just a wacky voicemail let's listen to
this one i don't even know what this is
yeah i don't tell you what man i don't
have enough of your daniel level
[ __ ] man
you know you you vote for hillary man
you were done voting for benghazi and
man
[ __ ] like you got like the her email man
the hell like going on like they don't
even got her email
what what man
i don't even give a [ __ ] man like you
know daniel q9
man [ __ ] the police man is this a pro or
and i don't know what the political bent
is of that
can anybody identify whether that that
person likes the show or doesn't
i'm gonna have to listen to that i can't
tell if that person is praising me
what is this gentleman saying yeah i
don't tell you what man i don't have
enough of your daniel level [ __ ] man
you know you vote for hillary man you
were done voting for benghazi and man
[ __ ] like you got like the her email man
the hell that's going on like they don't
even gotten her email and [ __ ] man
i don't even give a [ __ ] man like you
know daniel q and
man [ __ ] the police man if peop if
anybody wants that for a remix just
email in through the website
i cannot understand that for the life of
me i don't know what that person's
talking about
um and then i do have one troy york
voicemail uh oh hold on a second though
hold on a second heads up i do want to
thank the nine the
four additional folks who just signed up
via twitch but i am seeing
memberships fly in let's thank some
people gerald kramer just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
debbie bro signed up at joinedpakman.com
mert disgen signed up at
joinedpakman.com thanks to porsha
brunette
tron bardguard is a new member so is
steven lobo
cat gravel and amy richardson have
signed up
everett sodder as well as chris johnson
are new members
and uh wow angela higley has also
signed up thank you that puts us at 30.
i very much appreciate that
um okay
all right and then here is just one more
voicemail for us this
is the eggman uh very very mad at me
about
gamestop i guess all right yes uh daniel
peckman i'd like to know why
um for the past few days you've not
mentioned
or made mention of the gamestop stock
situation
and how um i'm curious if you're worried
it is curious but i i mentioned it the
day i mean we've been talking about i
think we talked about
the game stop situation every day
every day i mean we're off on weekends
but every day i talked about it
the globalist that the manipulation of
the markets and the
manipulation whoa what is on troy york's
mind today media by
a small upper one percent wall street
finance class
um somehow could be threatened by this i
know she said nothing
no we did an entire segment on it the
segment was even posted to wall street
bets and people seem to like it
i think you are in support of the urban
one percent i'm not in support of any i
what my position is i invest
in really low fee index funds for the
long term
and accumulate and reinvest dividends
and i own very few individual stocks
but if you are going to short stocks
you are accepting certain risks and you
can't then say when the risks go
south well protect me from the risks the
whole reason you're shorting a stock is
because there's a possible reward
you've got to accept the risk as well uh
wall street crowd because most of them
donate to
uh progressive causes i don't know that
that's true
liberals they're part of big tech robin
hood shuts down prevents the average
person from
yeah i'm against what robin hood did
being able to trade and purchase
gamestop
you are a fraud you're what's the fraud
i committed
political progressive is fake you people
believe in preference
falsification um
this is a term that should be used more
for the mainstream globalist left-wing
media look
notice the times he uses the word
globalist it's code word for jew
you guys are all frauds the the wall
street funders
they fund these same health public
officials who are unelected they're on
democrat
yet they can they're undemocrat what
does that mean
cut down business on their will
they make the decision this is like a
verbal ink blot test
um yeah these people who
own hedge funds are mostly foreigners
globalists
i think he's talking about jews guys
okay so we're gonna get away from that
um big thank you to paul archuleta every
time i hear archuletta
my my fellow breaking bad fans are going
to
like this anytime i hear the last name
archuleta i'm reminded
of the situation in which the i believe
it's the janitor
mr archuleta at the high school gets
arrested
for the theft of some elements of meth
making even though it was
walt of course who was doing that and i
remember
uh walt jr coming in and saying they
arrested mr archuletta
and uh that's what i think of okay
anyway paul archuleta just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
david klett just signed up tristan
williams
and enda gormley are new members
bethany baker and karen clark have just
signed up
judith gallagher and bjorn trail johnson
are new members thanks to franziska
iselli for the new membership as well as
sherry wanch wow this is crazy
eric harrison and miguel alvarado
are new members also zachariah
flanagan and jayla montgomery that's
14 and dario mirecki
15. memberships are dropping out of
nowhere
it's nuts um let me get to a few
super chats stephen chapman says david
do you know any youtubers on the right
who fight the radical aspects of the
right the idea being to deprogram
radical viewers while maintaining core
values
so they don't feel so completely
attacked no i don't
no i don't wendy the terror says i just
think of pork chops
i guess the word archuleta reminds you
of pork chops
david hernandez says love your show
appreciate it yabbitt says your
interviews are fantastic the one with
david livingstone smith alone was worth
my membership for the year
a happy renewer appreciate that yabbitz
uh whoa extreme zoom
what's going on here let's see
is this live it is
seems like something should be happening
soon let's hope so
given a quadratic polynomial ax squared
plus bx plus c equals 0 roots
are at negative b plus or minus the
square root of b
squared minus 4ac all over 2a
beautiful beautiful i love it
i love it i'm from i'm a lincoln
from wyoming i'm a lincoln from wyoming
and i'm looking for support for liz and
letters to barrasso to vote for
impeachment
what does that mean i'm a lincoln
it was boomhauer is that a is that a
meme reference i don't understand what
is boomhauer
boomhauer fictional character
oh it's from king of the hill let's see
i think i would have noticed something
like that
they're pretty rare aren't they oh yes
very rare and beautiful
sir do you know anything about this yeah
man i'll tell you what dude
one of them snap puns last night man
with them stick to bag and quack quack
man we'd go
oh this is what it's a oh let me listen
to it let me re-listen to it then with
that
i i'm not a king of the hill guy so i'm
not uh familiar with that
let's re-listen to it and see if that's
the uh
that's the joke okay so here's here's
boomhauer
talking about that big mistake y'all
right there in that cooler
okay and then here's the guy who called
me yeah i don't tell you what man i
don't have enough of your dango level
[ __ ] man is you know you
you vote for hillary man you've done
voting for benghazi and man
[ __ ] like you got like they're her email
manager
failed like i think that is the i think
that's that's a match yeah
going on like they don't even got me her
email and [ __ ] man i don't even
give a [ __ ] man like you know daniel
cunanan man
okay that's that's fantastic uh this is
why i need people to help me understand
the
the memes very very much appreciate it
okay thoughts on robin hood selling
people's gme stock i'm against it and
think it's completely disgusting and
they need to be held accountable
there's no other there's no other way to
say it all right here we go
just have a couple of things for all of
you at the top
first over the weekend the president's
homeland security advisor dr
liz sherwood randall convened a
coordination call with the acting fema
administrator
and the director of the national weather
service on the storm system moving
toward
the mid-atlantic region it's not just
moving toward i think it's clear it's
here if you look outside of our window
and up the eastern seaboard liz and her
team joined the fema daily operations
briefing yesterday
and remain in regular contact with the
fema response team about
changes in the storm forecast and any
need for federal assistance
the white house wanted to assess the
potential impact and determine any
early action that the federal government
could take to support communities across
many states likely to be affected liz
also proactively called governors of
states in the storm's path overnight
and into today and she will remain in
close touch
those include governor cuomo governor
murphy governor wolf governor carney
as well as new york city mayor de blasio
she expressed the president's intent to
ensure close coordination going forward
among federal state and local officials
in preparing for and responding to
weather emergencies also as you
many of you have noted the president
spoke with senator collins yesterday as
you all know
invited her and other senate republicans
to the white house later this afternoon
this meeting is part of the president
and his administrations our
administration's close
and ongoing engagement with members of
both parties and
capitol hill and on the american rescue
package throughout those conversations
we've underscored the economic
and health challenges that our country
faces issues he will of course be
reiterating today
and the need to move swiftly to address
them with a package that is big enough
to get schools safely reopen give
financially struggling families and kids
a huge package
and deliver on his promise to speed up
vaccine
delivery and defeat the virus uh it's
important to remember that the size of
the package was designed with the size
of the crisis
right a dual crisis as we've said and i
wanted to just
call out a couple of economists and some
economic data
that we've seen over the last several
days a new report by the brookings
institution estimates that with the
american rescue plan we could boost gdp
by four percent
and return our economy to pre-covered
levels by the end of 2021.
a separate analysis by moody's analytics
found that the president's plan would
create 7.5 million jobs this year
and double our economic growth and
return our economy back to full
employment
one year faster the imf's chief
economist said their
preliminary analysis found that the plan
could boost u.s economic growth
by five percent over three years
a couple of other just updates for you
just today uh the u.s conference of
mayors sent a letter to congressional
leadership
urging them to take immediate action on
the american rescue
plan this letter was signed by over 400
mayors i know there's a lot going on so
just wanted to highlight it for all of
you
and west virginia governor jim justice
also a republican said in interviews
today
that he agrees that going big in this
moment is critical and last thing i just
want to do before we get to your
questions
well write the questions i'm going to
circle back i hate to disappoint
conservative twitter but i am going to
circle back
oh thanks as we often do directly but
hurricane maria funds
which was a question that was asked last
week the president has made clear
the status of them i should say that it
is a priority for his administration to
release this funding
we are working to do so we're circling
back process
on the white house fence which a couple
of people asked about i believe it was
on friday
uh our goal the president and the vice
president's goal is uh
for the secret service to adjust the
perimeter as soon as it makes sense from
an overall security
standpoint so we're working closely with
them on that
and they of course would be in the lead
on that front
and the last piece i just wanted to give
a quick update on was there was a
question about
the white house's support for fema's
request of troops
we of course support a whole of
government pandemic response that is
catering to the unique issues and needs
of our states
fema's working in strong partnership
with states to get a handle on their
needs
and accordingly have requested the
significant manpower in some cases
for this unprecedented pandemic response
effort
i expect we'll have more on this as the
days continue this week
on how they will be utilized uh with
that let's go darlene welcome to the
let's do it
i know you've been here many times
before but it's our first engagement
here go ahead
on the president's meeting this evening
with the senators can you give us a
sense of
how he views that meeting is it going to
be negotiating is he going to be
prepared to counter
anything that the republicans might
offer or is it just
a session where you know they asked me
with the president and he's simply
giving them an opportunity
to voice their concerns well the
president has been
clear since long before he came into
office that
he's open to engaging with both
democrats and republicans in congress
about their ideas and
this is an example of doing exactly that
so as we said in our statement last
night
it's an exchange of ideas an opportunity
to do that
this group obviously sent a letter uh
with some outlines some top lines of of
their
concerns and their priorities and he's
happy to have a conversation with them
what this meeting is not is a forum for
the president to make or accept an
offer so i think that's important to
convey to all of you
and his view it remains uh what uh was
stated in the statement last night but
also what he said on friday which is
that
the risk is not that it is uh too big
this package the risk
is that it is too small uh and that
remains his view and it's one hill
certainly you don't want to end up
holding a package that's too small
so what would you say is more important
to the president at this point on this
first
legislative test is it going big or
going bipartisan
it seems like you can't have both
well i think the president believes we
can and there is uh historic
uh evidence uh that it is possible to
take a number of paths
uh including uh through reconciliation
if that's the path that is pursued
and for the vote to be bipartisan but
it's important to him that he hears
this group out on their concerns on
their ideas
he's always open to making this package
stronger
and he also as was noted in our
statement last night remains in close
touch with speaker pelosi
with leader schumer and he will continue
that engagement throughout the day and
in the days ahead
that's good you mentioned that president
biden's proposed covet
relief package is designed to be
commensurate with the crises
this group of 10 senate republicans what
they're offering as you know
is more than a third less the top line
number the 600 billion is more than the
third less of that 1.9 trillion that
president biden says he wants
given that do you use less than
one-third of the attempt to compromise
on their part
weird way to say it well i appreciate
the opportunity to give more comments
i think it's they put their ideas
forward that's how the president sees it
he felt it was uh you know an effort to
engage and engage on a bipartisan basis
and that's why he invited them
to the white house today but listen
invite him to the white house
give them until tonight or tomorrow
morning and then just pass the thing
without them through budget
reconciliation it's an emergency
these people are not good faith actors
just pass it without them
the president plan to invite democrats
into the oval to have these similar
conversations
well i can promise you we're less than
two weeks in there will be many
democrats in the oval office and i'm
sure
this is just the you know part of our
ongoing effort to engage directly
well asking that again in a slightly
different way
there are democrats who see that the
first meeting
the president is having face to face
with lawmakers is with republicans and
not democrats
i guess why would that why is the white
house doing hopefully to then just say
let's pass
no but it's been talked about there's
concerns there's people talking about it
in hallways
okay um well i can assure you that
speaker pelosi and senator and leader
schumer
uh they have been in very close touch
with the president directly and members
of the senior team
uh he has been in touch uh but also
members of our senior team have been in
touch with democrats
across the political spectrum and that
will continue and there will be
definitely democrats who will be part of
conversations here at the white house
on that you said in your statement that
the scale of what must be done
is large that's bottom line is 618
billion dollars
considered large by the white house well
i think our statement last night made
clear
that uh the president believes that the
risk is not
being too going too small but going uh
going uh
not big enough um and uh that his view
uh is that the size of the package needs
to be commensurate with the crises we're
facing that's why he proposed 1.9
trillion
there's obviously a big gap between 600
billion and 1.9 children i don't think
any of us are
mathematicians otherwise we wouldn't be
here but we can all state that
clearly and so clearly he thinks the
package size needs to be closer to what
he proposed than
smaller plate you call that 1400 relief
checks a substantial investment in
fighting covenant reopening schools ate
the small businesses
hurting families a lot of that isn't in
the republican proposal
so why have this meeting at all if
there's
going to take seriously what he has
proposed well again ed this is
an exchange an opportunity to exchange
ideas to have a conversation
uh that's why he invited them over here
see this is either all really good
questioning
or or useless if if biden's just putting
a meeting with republicans on the record
and then just going to say we're moving
along with budget reconciliation screw
you guys
hey great we gave them a meeting their
proposal was ridiculous
if he's actually going to allow them to
prevent a substantive package from being
passed
then it's a problem to ensure that you
know we can
get the vaccine in the arms of americans
so there are some
real impacts which he will certainly
reiterate as he has
publicly and privately in many
conversations but
they've put forward some ideas he's
happy to hear from them but he's uh
also feels uh strongly about the need to
make sure the size of the package meets
this moment and and feels the american
people expect that of their elected
officials as well
sure the statement the president just
put out among other things that says the
united states is taking note of those
who stand with the people of burma
in this difficult hour is that perhaps a
message to china
i think it's a message to all countries
in the region
and countries who you know will be asked
to respond uh or to consider what the
appropriate response will be
um in reaction to uh the events that
have happened over the past couple of
days
uh thank you on friday we heard the
president come out and say that while he
wants to pass this bill
with support from republicans if we can
get it it has to pass with no no ifs
ands or buts as he put it
and if we can get it part should we take
that as a sign that the president
recognizes
he may have to be abandoning his hopes
for bipartisanship
i think it's hardly an abandoning of
bipartisanship we're
still at a phase where the house and
senate are working through as you know
from covering congress
uh the entire reconciliation what the
process would look like on the budgetary
front this week
uh senator leader schumer and speaker
pelosi have both said they would also
like it to
be bipartisan we'll see what comes out
of this meeting today
and if there are good ideas to put
forward we'll put forward them there's
still time to do exactly that
and even if through the parliamentary
process that the congress will decide
it moves toward reconciliation
republicans can still vote for that and
there's certainly
a precedent of that in the past you
mentioned that the republicans can still
vote for the bill obviously even if it's
done through reconciliation but some
republican sources say that's not
really bipartisanship it doesn't satisfy
that promise because it's not true
compromise
well i think that the one in seven
american families who can't put food on
the table and the
teachers who are waiting to ensure their
schools have
the ventilation the ppe the testing they
need
uh those they will tell you that they
expect their members to meet this moment
and uh we saw this as a good faith
proposal they put forward good faith
effort to have a discussion
the president's inviting them here in
good faith uh
and we will see where it goes from all
these questions about why is biden
meeting with them in 24 hours we'll know
what the result is of that meeting and
what happens to the package that's being
proposed and then we'll evaluate
it's going to be much harder to achieve
down the road on other issues the
president
is confident that issues like reopening
schools
getting shots in the arms of americans
ensuring people have enough food to eat
are not just democratic issues
he takes his former republican
colleagues
at their word of course that they're
committed to these issues too
and that's why he wants to have the
conversation go ahead
thanks john i want to ask you about
gamestop some
lawmakers have proposed legislative
reforms like
restrictions on short selling and
financial
transactions tax that the latter of
which uh president biden supported
during the 2020 campaign so i want to
ask you now if the white house
would support actions like those to
address the situation
well as we've noted in here several
times before but i just want to
reiterate obviously this is under the
purview of the sec in terms of
their review and monitoring but this is
uh there is an important set of policy
issues
that have been raised as a result of
market volatility in recent days and
we think what would be the repercussions
if she said something like biden has
options
at 120 dollars per share like if if a
press secretary said something like that
that everybody would explode right
rather than um we certainly uh welcome
the opportunity to work with members who
have proposed ideas there's been any
direct engagement with those members so
far and what they proposed
uh i don't have anything to read out for
you on that front obviously we're
engaged um
at a variety of levels every day with a
range of offices on
a number of issues um so but i don't
have anything more for you on that
lastly one more on this sorry
um is so there's no confirmed members
right now on the financial stability
oversight council
and is it the white house view that that
lack of
like officials in place is affecting
your administration's approach to this
situation
well again the sec is looking um
carefully at recent activities um
and if they're consistent with investor
protection and fair and efficient
markets
that's where we think the purview is and
the focus is at this point in time
go ahead if i can ask one follow up on
the meeting with the republicans and
then i'll follow up on the second
question as well
let's follow the timeline that the
president sees for these negotiations
to end what is the i mean how urgent is
this if
these benefits are going to end in the
middle of march how much time is it i
have these types of meetings as you say
with democrats and others that may want
to take part
it's incredibly urgent uh and as you
noted there is
um you know there are uh there are
not not there are timelines coming up i
should say in terms of
when the americans who are applying for
unemployment insurance will no longer be
able to
get access as i noted earlier one in
seven
american families uh doesn't have enough
can't put food on the table
we need to plan for how we're going to
get more vaccines in the arms of
americans
we need to have funding to help public
schools have the preparations needed to
reopen so
there is urgency this is what the
president is spending his time on
uh as as evidenced by the meeting later
today and what the majority of our
senior team is focused on at this moment
but there is still time to make changes
um to continue to have a discussion and
that's why he's
were kind of escalating the number of
meetings and engagements we're having
through the course of this week
on the president's statement that he put
out he says the reverse toll of progress
will necessitate an immediate review of
our sanctions laws and authorities
followed by appropriate action
is the appropriate action related solely
to sanctions or what other type of
response may be on the table
well i think that's why uh the pres that
was called out in the president's
comments as you know uh we removed
sanctions the united states i should say
remove sanctions on burma over the past
decade based on
progress toward democracy the reversal
of that progress will necessitate an
immediate review
of our sanctions laws and authorities
followed by appropriate action
so that's why he called it out i don't
have anything any additional steps
beyond that to
predict for you at this point in time
some democrats are hoping to repeal the
ten thousand dollar cap on
state and local tax deductions in the
coba bill does
uh does the president support those
insertions and more broadly does he
support
a general repeal of that deduction uh
you know the president supports
uh democrats and republicans putting
good ideas forward and having a
discussion about them and i'd rather a
better
position how we move forward with
urgency to get this plan passed but i'm
not going to negotiate from here
senator manchin was a little upset with
uh some comments the vice president made
on the local television show
has the white house reached out to him
in any way to kind of clear the air
we've been in touch with senator manchin
as we have been for
the salt limit on the deduction really
hurts people in blue states more than
red states and it was a disgusting
element of the trump
bill the trump tax reform bill i would
love to see biden just take the position
yeah we want to get rid of that last
question um in regards to
my mom what if any efforts are being
made to coordinate a response with
allies such as japan eu and britain and
have you has there been any contacts
with china to discuss the situation
uh well um
we have had um intensive consultations
at multiple levels with allies and
partners in the region and around the
world
i would expect many of those would come
through the state department
um so i'd certainly uh def refer to them
for more specifics
hans yeah do i just follow burma in your
statement last night when you said you
might take action
you referred to it as burma and myanmar
and then the president's statement just
now
he only uses burma is that indicative of
a formal shift to the united states
government on how we're
going good question
well our official policy is that we save
burma but use myanmar as a courtesy in
certain communications uh
so for example the embassy web site
refers to burm
myanmar because they are by definition
dealing with officials and the public
uh the state department website uses
burma myanmar and some places in burma
and others
so there's no official change you last
night used both and the president goes
four times with burma was he meaning to
be
discourteous uh i i don't think that's
the conclusion you should draw uh
certainly he is watching this closely
yes he was deliberately being
discourteous
like when trump said the china plays
still time for negotiation can you be a
little bit more specific
is um president trying to get this one
week two weeks
to try to come up with a bipartisan
solution and then secondly the cbo
said this morning that the economy
should return to pre-pandemic levels by
about big year even if there's not
additional legislation so how does that
assessment affect
what your effective negotiations so on
the first i'm not going to give a
deadline here other than to say
that it is urgent we move forward for
all the reasons we've already been
discussing
including the need to ensure families
can put food on the table the need to
ensure we have
time to plan for getting schools the
necessary funding to
reopen the need to ensure we can get
vaccines in the arms of americans
clearly there's urgency as you know and
as many of you know who cover congress
there's a process that's ongoing this
week there's still some time here
as that process works its way through
for changes to be made so that was what
i was referring to uh on the second
question
sorry where can you create the second
question the cbo here
projection this morning that the economy
is going to return to pre-pandemic size
by the middle of the year and that's
without any additional
stimulus well the the president's plan
as we've been discussing in here was
designed to achieve certain basic goals
um
getting shots in the arms of americans
helping the one in seven families uh who
are going hungry
and the nearly seven million americans
who are facing possible eviction during
a pandemic
the cbo projections for next year's
growth isn't a measure of all of these
things
right it's not a measure of how each
american family is doing and whether
the american people are getting the
assistance they need or whether we're
able to get vaccines in the shots of
of of people so um you know we've uh
of course it answers a different
question i should say so our focus is on
um what the american people need to get
through this crisis which is why we are
pushing for this piece of legislation
go ahead thanks jen um on school
reopening
the democratic mayor of chicago has said
that it's safe to reopen schools they've
invested 100 million
into safety measures but the teachers
there remain on the verge of striking
does the white house agree with the
mayor that if enough funding has been
put into place and safety measures have
been taken that that kids should return
to schools
well let me first say the president has
been has enormous respect for mayor
lightfoot and
he has also been a strong ally to
teachers
his entire career of course as you know
dr biden his wife is a teacher so
even in his home he trusts the mayor and
the unions
to work this out they're both
prioritizing the right things which is
ensuring the health and safety of the
kids and teachers
and working to make sure the children in
chicago are getting the education
they deserve so he is hopeful we are
hopeful they can reach common ground as
soon as possible
to play here though chicago and other
cities in terms of mediating
these negotiations and getting kids back
to school we certainly
remain in touch with a range of parties
but again we hope that
they can come to common ground soon and
just lastly on the
overall code relief package in terms of
understanding
what you know the white house means by
by
partisan um would you consider a bill
bipartisan
if it doesn't have any republican
support in congress but it has
uh you know support among republican
voters
well i think you touched on an
interesting point which is i would say
yes
according to recent polls supports this
package i have a segment today about
this
democrats and republicans we just saw
the republican governor of west virginia
come out earlier today
and advocate for a big package um so
you know when the president talks about
unifying the country and bringing the
country together
he's not suggesting that he is going to
if 80 percent of the country agrees with
something but no republicans are willing
to vote for it and biden does it anyway
it's representative of the people feels
they made a good faith effort to put a
the top lines of a proposal forward and
he wants to
have that engagement and encourages that
of sharing of ideas
so i don't think it's an either or uh
but i think
it's a both and we certainly feel that
the components that are in this package
are the basis of what should garner
bipartisan support
based on the polling you cited if
there's not enough republican support in
congress would that be considered
bipartisan based on the measures
he's setting for himself i will let you
be the judge of that
um go ahead thank you very much john um
i
have a question for for one reporter who
couldn't be here because
of distancing that's a question from
cleveland from the washington post
what kind of preparations went into vice
president harris's interviews in
the west with west virginia stations
yesterday or last week
i'm not sure what your question is what
kind of what preparations went into
vice president harris's interviews with
uh local stations
like how does your team prepare her or
can it be more was it part of a larger
white house strategy to put pressure on
on politicians in west virginia our
focus
the bottom line is our focus is
communicating with the american people
about
how the american rescue plan can help
put food on well we brought in chris
christie to play the role of the
interviewer with
the school that's our overarching
objective with all of the communications
we do
after uh senator manchin's criticism of
that interview did
president biden personally speak with
senator manchin well as i as i noted
before an earlier question we're
certainly in touch with senator manchin
and his team as we have been for some
time and will continue to be and he's an
important partner
as we look to move forward on this
package and of course all of the
president's agenda and i
have a question about the meeting with
republican senators today
the proposal that they put forward would
take the
over 300 billion in aid to states and
local
governments that biden has put forward
and zero that out would there be no
aid in their proposal to state and local
governments is that a non-starter for
president biden i mean can can he even
move forward with a proposal like that
well there is a reason that that funding
is in the initial proposal
um including you know sometimes the
definition of calling it state and local
means people don't know what it means
right it is and i'm not suggesting
you're doing that we've probably
short-handed it too
um you know that is funding for
firefighters for
um you know local communities for
enabling them to help get through this
period of time
i'm not going to outline for you what
the red lines are from the podium
when there's discussions that are
ongoing but again
the reason that each component was put
in the package is because
economists health experts uh many that
the president and others consulted with
felt there were
essential components to help get the
american people through this period of
time
can i follow up on a state law sure
republicans appointed jen do you think
nick from the backstreet boys is a
little too aggressive about telling the
others they can't sing
increase in tax revenues as an example
of why that
state local tax relief or state local
really isn't needed in this
latest package well again i think um our
objective is to focus on
uh not jp morgan reports but what um
state local governments and others are
telling us they need to ensure that the
people in their districts
uh the resources in their districts the
people who are making government
function their districts
have the have the funding and resources
they need
uh go ahead hi amish hi how are you
two questions the first is does the
president support house democrats moving
forward
with the process of reconciliation today
there's some reporting that they're
waiting for the
guidance from the white house the
president as was noted in the statement
last night
is uh grateful for the urgency and the
pace at which they're moving and
as you know this process can take a
little bit of time
um so but he certainly supports them
moving forward
i'm pausing what i would love here is
for her to say
the president is working this and
understands
that congress will be a regular
check on the speed with which the
president goes through this
if they determine they want to start
that process that will be their decision
to make
uh to to move a package uh ahead uh but
again
um you know this the the process through
the mechanics through which they
move is up to them he's leaving it up to
them there we go he
believes that there is still room uh for
bipartisan support for this package
which is why he's having this meeting
today
and why he'll remain very engaged
himself and why he's asked his senior
team to remain very engaged in the days
ahead
the follow-up to that with
reconciliation is there a timeline
that this white house is looking at as
okay now we have to move forward
in the white house's mind or in the
president's mind to say okay we have to
move forward at this state
again urgent means urgent um it means
this is going to be the focus of the
president the vice president now
she obviously can't say but
joe biden has a deadline of wednesday
night and then he's saying go go for it
you know
she obviously is not in a position to be
able to say that in his senior team
uh hence he's having a group of
republican senators here later today
he will continue to be closely engaged
with not just speaker pelosi and leader
schumer but
a range of democrats as will members of
our team um
and the fact that he's spending so much
time on it and our team is shows you
how much of a priority it is here i
asked you about kovid
there i know there was a covered
briefing today but one statistic that
really stood out to me and probably to a
lot of americans is
about 47 percent of vaccinations are
coming in with no
with racial data it means more than 50
don't have racial data
i'm wondering if the president has a fix
for that if there's a legislative or a
policy
change that's going to be made because
i'm wondering how you
ensure that the virus that the vaccine
is given equitably if you don't know
who's getting it
well um first you know the the racial
disparities in the impact of this
pandemic are not lost on the president
and that's one of the reasons he asked
dr marcela nunez smith who was of course
part of the briefing this morning
to lead this task force um and why he
campaigned on the need for response
rooted in addressing the
disproportionate impact on communities
of color
there are a couple of steps that we are
taking substantively
one includes standing up and supporting
additional venues for vaccinations
targeted at reaching those at the
highest risk
and the community's hardest hit by this
pandemic so going into communities and
meeting people
where they are and not expecting you
know every community to go out and seek
and search
where they can find the vaccine meeting
with states to discuss their plans for
ensuring equitable vaccine distribution
and offering assistance in achieving
that goal so
as you all know and we've talked about
in here governors
are obviously overseeing the the
distribution
and efforts to ensure that the vaccine
is getting into communities across the
country we are closely engaged with them
and looking for ways to help assist in
that front
and think uh strategically and
creatively about how to do that
and we're also working with cdc to
identify and explore ways to urgently
improve the quality of vaccination data
reporting by race and ethnicity there's
no question it's not
the level that we need it to be at a
directive that's going to happen or is
there
a message to the people that are that
are giving out the vaccines we
we need this data i just wonder how that
actually gets changed
on the ground level is that is it a
president i don't know if it's a
presidential memorandum or a policy
change
i'm just wondering if someone walks into
cvs how did that person
taking their data saying yes the white
house needs me to get this data from
this person
well again this is equity is um is
essential
uh and a priority in all everything we
do including addressing
covid and the pandemic which is the
president's top priority
i would certainly uh defer to our health
and medical expert so i know spoke to
this a bit this morning and i think
um dr marcela nunez smith will be out
more in the next 24 hours or so talking
more about steps we can take
on this front go ahead have a follow-up
to amisha's great question about
reconciliation and it's that the
senate republican leader mitch mcconnell
back in 2017 famously said
um winners make policy losers go home
given that why shouldn't democrats why
shouldn't president biden be as
tactically ruthless
as republicans have been yes and pushing
priorities
that he champions why not well i think
the president has been clear that he
is encouraged by the pace and
the rapid pace i should say uh that
speaker pelosi and senator schumer
are moving this package forward at at
the same time as you know
there is time uh because this this
process can take a bit
uh to make changes as needed and he
wants to be a part of those
conversations hence he invited
republicans
to do that exactly here today i can't
speak to
um to um senator mcconnell's
role or commitment or point of view or
or anything he's certainly not asking me
to be a spokesperson lord knows but
you know the president biden ran on a
commitment
of of course unifying the country but
also of
hearing from all sides and giving having
engaging and having an opportunity to
have discussions and today is part of
doing that
and quickly can i circle back to use
that phrase to a question i asked during
the transition
anyone can steal it just means you have
to give back so i'll circle back to this
has the white house made a determination
about whether it will continue to extend
the privilege of intelligence briefings
to former president trump
given the concerns among some democrats
that he'll either use it or leverage it
to enrich himself
this is a good question i've raised it
with our intelligence teams or our
national security team i should say it's
something obviously that's under review
but um there was not a conclusion unless
i asked him about it but i'm happy to
follow up on it and see if there's more
to show i would be curious
all right thank you jen last friday a
few dozen men from the white supremacist
group patriot
front were filmed marching on the
national mall toward the capitol
uh what is what is the administration's
latest threat assessment on white
supremacist groups
like this coming to washington is the
threat seen as increasing well
i think the fact that there was a
tasking done through our national
security team on domestic violent
extremism
that is going to review all activity
that could pose a threat including the
activities of white supremacists
tells you what a priority is and tells
you that we believe that there is more
that needs to be done and a greater
assessment
um so that review is ongoing as soon as
it's concluded i'm sure we'll have
more to share with all of you about our
view at this point in time
go ahead thanks uh on just a bit of a
housekeeping matter
since the senate delayed its
confirmation vote on alejandro mayorkas
does that mean that the immigration
rollout that you guys have linked to
that confirmation is going to be
pushed back as well well we are
certainly hopeful he will be confirmed
tomorrow and we
have every intention of moving forward
tomorrow with the immigration executive
actions that we have uh discussed in
here a bit
go ahead in the back thank you uh last
week a statue of kahatma gandhi was
desecrated vandalized in city of davis
in california
uh these artists among the indian
americans others followers of gandhi in
this country
uh the president knows about it and that
has been thought and this for the third
time this has happened in this country
last one year last two times to happen
in this city itself in washington dc
well we certainly would have concern
about the desecration of monuments of
gandhi um
and i uh you know that's certainly what
we would express where you ask
sorry what was the last part of the
question you were asking does the
president noah
knows about it and what are his thoughts
on it uh
if there's more to share on the
president's point of view on it i'm
happy to get back to you on that but
certainly we would um you know condemn
that desecration and
and watch it closely question do you
do you recognize the new uh army
leadership in burma or you don't
recognize that the legislative
government in government
well i think our statement makes clear
what our view is
on the events of the last few days uh
and where we stand
uh with the you know declared new
government
uh as you know president trump has been
barred from a lot of social media sites
it's curious whether you think his
absence has made your job any easier or
the white house's job any easier as it
kind of
shouldn't even comment on negotiations
in what way
well he created a lot of noise right he
would he would have certain
gravitational pull with republicans who
may be
maybe more inclined to take a harder
position i wonder if that's
been anything that you guys have thought
about or kind of
considered this may be hard to believe
we don't spend a lot of time talking
about our thinking about president trump
here former president trump uh
to be very clear um i think that's a
question that's probably more
appropriate for
republican members you should also say i
wasn't press secretary under trump so i
don't have anything to compare
to who um are looking for ways to
support a bipartisan package and whether
that gives them space but i can't say we
miss him on twitter
does president obama support the
continuing ban of president no position
i think that's a decision made by
twitter we've certainly spoken to and
he's spoken to
um the need for social media platforms
to continue to take steps to
reduce hate speech um but we don't have
more for you on it than that the
president
is trying to um keep touch with basic
amer everyday americans such as
getting a sampling of letters that are
sentient as some past presidents have
done
especially as it relates to the pandemic
that's such a good question you know he
um is looking to remain engaged it's
hard when we haven't done any travel yet
and we're certainly hoping to do that at
some point in time
um to to engage with americans more
directly
i don't have anything specific he does
receive of course
letters it takes some time for them to
come in as you know they
kind of go through a process once they
are arrive at the white house
uh that's something he's eager to have
access to
uh obviously there's also um you know
many ways to
provide feedback or input to the white
house which he's eager to receive too
but
let me see if i can get more detail for
you does joe biden plan to tweet more
including maybe insulting people
you won that go ahead darling uh another
housekeeping question do you know if all
10 senators
are coming to the meeting this evening
it's a great question
but are they all coming uh i don't have
a uh official
um uh manifest but we will venture to
circle back with all of you on that
after the briefing
if i can ask another one on burma the
president's statement that just came out
he's calling on the international
community
to come together in one voice to press
the burmese military to reverse what
they've done
but do the events at the capitol on
january 6 make it harder for the united
states to be part of this international
community
that he's calling on look i think
president biden i don't think the
international community sees president
biden
as a root of the events on january 6th
and certainly he has
made every effort through conversations
directly with partner and allah and
partners and allies
through how he has spoken publicly in
disgust about the events on january 6
and through his own commitment to
restoring rule of law
democracy here in the united states the
united states
remains a country in the world that is
looked to
for you know leadership and it's going
to take some
time but he's certainly committed to
doing that thank you
go ahead another housekeeping related
capital does the president or anyone
else
here plan to visit wednesday to pay
respects to officers
i will check on his schedule for you ed
on if there's more uh to outline for you
go ahead hans you may get into this
tomorrow if we have an immigration
preview related
if for unaccompanied migrants arriving
at the border now
after that appeals court decision are
they being turned away right now
we're going to have a briefing tonight
um for all of you on our actions
tomorrow and the president will have
more to say
so we'll i'll refer to that i may be
back one of the
subjects one of the items that's going
to be discussed we don't i'm not going
to preview it more for you we're still
kind of doing the final review believe
it or not
but uh we'll have a briefing tonight in
advance of our
announcement tomorrow great thank you
everyone
there it is
[Applause]
and there goes gensaki
very very important uh press briefing
today uh all right very good
i may be back for that other briefing
tonight
uh make sure to send me um
articles or videos you want me to go
over on future streams
memes and song parodies of course always
welcome make sure if you've been
watching
on twitch that you follow me on twitch
make sure if you're watching on youtube
that you subscribe
and make sure you like if you're
watching on facebook all right everybody
i'll be back with you very soon